es un peligro inminente un enorme
embalse de aguas residuales
amenaza con romperse en la localidad de
paine y point cerca de la ciudad de
tampa tras la detección de grietas en la
estructura los equipos de emergencia
trabajan a contrarreloj intentando
evitar una catástrofe medioambiental en
la bahía el gobernador del estado ron de
santis declaró estado de emergencia el
sábado y pidió responsabilidades a la
empresa hr k propietaria del embalse lo
que estamos viendo ahora es para tratar
de prevenir y responder si es necesario
a una situación de inundación
catastrófica real también quiero ser
claro si bien nuestra principal
preocupación es garantizar la seguridad
de la comunidad nuestra administración
está dedicada a hacer cumplir por
completo cualquier daño a los recursos
de nuestro estado y responsabilizar a la
empresa
hr cam porque este evento se estima que
la balsa contiene unos 480 millones de
galones de agua mucha de ella usada en
el procesado de fosfatos sin embargo un
colapso del depósito podría hacer que el
yeso fosforado
residuo radiactivo para la producción de
fertilizantes almacenado en la zona se
ha arrastrado y con también el
ecosistema
por ello el condado manatí ordenó la
evacuación de más de 300 casas de la
zona aunque muchos no creen que sea
razón suficiente para abandonar sus
domicilios descarte este terreno es un
poco más alto que el de otras áreas así
que preferimos quedarnos aquí y venir ni
con los huracanes y todo nueva kwamos
aquí de momento los trabajadores de
emergencia desplegados están descargando
33 millones de galones de agua al día
para frenar una inundación con aguas
tóxicas a este ritmo tomaría entre 10 y
12 días completar la operación de manera
segura